my guest tonight is an emmy and
grammy-nominated comedian and actor
she can currently be seen killing
zombies piloting helicopters and smoking
cigars
in zack snyder's new netflix movie army
of the dead
she can also be seen exploring outer
space as jet reno
in star trek discovery her career has
gone places
i never imagined please welcome our good
friend
tig notaro tigg i
i couldn't be happier for you uh you're
one of my favorite guests
you're one of my favorite uh comedians
and your
career has just taken off you're in a
zack snyder film you're playing
jet reno in star trek yeah it's insanity
it's madness
got a little gas you got a little gas
you know what you really do have action
hero energy coming off you right now
and it's really helped by the fact that
your feet are
dangling off the chair
meet jet reno everybody i haven't even
talked yet
i know um
you know my wife gives me a hard time
about this because
i do i sit really far back in a chair
and a couch and my feet dangle is there
any way i could get a um
like a little stool or something to put
my that costs money
no i'm willing to pay that's fine look i
got action hero cash now
please is there a little something yes
oh good oh my god look at this
that is oh thank you so much okay
why are you still moving your feet
i'm excited to be here you've
accomplished nothing
you know um i'm delighted to see you and
seeing you here reminds me that we've
been here at the largo theater for how
long flanny we've been here
we've been here a year flannigan your
sidekick flanagan
is working hard to replace andy richter
flanny as we call him runs the largo
theater and that's what working hard
looks like
uh yeah and he's wearing his true irish
colors uh
which is apparently a neon pink yeah
um and uh but you know flanny well
because
you perform regularly here at the largo
theater before the pandemic yes
this is like your second home you must
have very strong memories of this place
i do but this is uh what if i didn't
remember anything
like nothing rang a bell well that's how
i feel about this pandemic anything
beforehand
is a vague memory yeah no it this is
i mean is it cheesy to say my home away
from home yep okay
well that's what i'm about is cheese um
but it really is my home away from home
you perform here all the time not just
that
let me tell you something you might not
know this
but um after my mother passed away i
inherited
her furniture and so
all of her pieces were around her house
and stephanie my wife was sick and tired
of the couch
and she was like listen this has to go
we have to get a new couch at least
and so i had a hard time parting with it
and so i thought you know what i bet
flanagan would let me store it uh
backstage at largo
so that's the blue couch that's been
behind you
on all your episodes that's my family
couch
this is your mom's couch yes and then
you gave it to
flanagan thinking can i store it and of
course now it's a tv star
it is a you should see the fan mail
i'm going to put that in in the
background of my action films and tv
shows now
it's yours to take you know what i can't
believe is flanagan
has filled this theater with i don't
know what else to say
knickknacks bric-a-brac garbage garbage
and junk
i was convinced that what is happening
back there
we shoot this [ __ ] what is that noise do
you hear that
yeah it's on the street well we're right
off the alley i know we're right off the
alley hello come on in who is it
i wouldn't say that because people have
yeah seriously who is it come out and
show yourself
who is it it was another truck on
loading something
i like how my [ __ ] here is ridiculous
there's an alley right here
and we're trying to cover it up by only
a curtain yes
there's there's and my interview is
getting directed at a truck driver in an
alley
yes you're like hello hi how are you say
something you're here
i'm over here being an action star
in the number one movie in the universe
and you're like talking to a truck
driver in an
alley that's the level of show business
we've seen you don't know what you have
i don't well i do know what we have it's
just we're next to an alley and i swear
to god they're constantly
there it's like there's a bowling alley
next door it's insane that one sounded
like
people fencing something yeah
there actually is a bowling alley next
door you
have done brilliant work on my show over
the years uh
i i think you have one of the most
original comedic voices that i've
encountered there's no one else like you
and you would come on our show and you
would do stuff that i hadn't seen
anybody do
uh well i didn't see anybody do anything
like it on other
late night spots and i thought this is a
real find this this tig no taro
i mean it was a joy it was a joy to
discover you and have you come on the
show
well i appreciate that the feeling is
mutual
and um and what was exciting for me
was um for you i mean
this wasn't the exciting part but for
years i was
turned down for talk shows and late
night or i'd have you know one shot or
no shot and
and i would get feedback that my
delivery was too slow or
too not enough jokes per minute i heard
and too low-key not mainstream enough
and then when i got a shot to come on
your show
i remember leaving
the studio and i got a call from my
manager
saying that um that that
your show had called to have me booked
again
immediately yes and that you wanted me
to be a regular on the show and i i
was i couldn't even comprehend that
because of all of the rejection
i had gotten and i feel like your show
gave me this
incredible opportunity to be myself to
try out
weird things and it also i'm certain um
went hand in hand with me being welcomed
onto so many other talk shows and um
well
i mean what i remember is you came on
your first show you did some really
unique impressions
that were really funny and we said oh
god she's really great
let's have her come back you came back
now most people in that situation would
say
i've got to be conservative i'm getting
my second shot i've got to make sure
it's safe
on your second shot for most of your
shot
for most of your act you slowly pushed a
stool
across the stage which was the gutsiest
thing
anybody would try even if it was your
15th time on the show
you might maybe you'd try it but it
would still feel risky
it was your second time on the show and
it was hilarious but
it was a stool bigger than this it was a
stool bigger than that and you remember
this andy and
tape was made a horrible noise which was
the point yeah it was the point
and you were pushing it around and
that was if someone had pitched that to
me i would have said
there's no way that's going to work
fortunately they didn't
you just did it well when i pitched it
um
to your producer probably jp buck
yeah exactly who jp um
he was like all right i trust you
i just let's let's see it and so he did
come down and
watch me do it i think at the comedy
store yeah and uh
and to be fair it doesn't work for a
long time
there's there is a long stretch there's
a long stretch where it's not working it
doesn't work and you have to commit to
it well also a shout out to jp buck who
does a beautiful job of
finding amazing people like you and uh
and and just making our enriching our
shows
conan i'll have you know i've been in
toronto for four weeks filming star trek
and was then in new york uh for the
tribeca film festival
i flew home just to do this episode
to say my farewells and my thank yous to
you because i have to go back to tribeca
after i do this that's crazy you flew
i'm told yeah you you were saying you
i got on the first flight this morning
and you flew here
went right to your house took a shower
my sons who i hadn't seen
at this point in five weeks said look
how big we got
how cute and sad at the same time i
hugged them
kissed them and uh and yeah after i took
a shower ran out the door
and came to largo so you're a terrible
parent is what you're saying i am
i'm i i choose you over my adorable
precious children
what i do with my kids whenever they
said daddy daddy we love you
as i put my hands over their faces and
push them away and say
show business first that's what i do
that's how they've grown up and they
understand now
they understand did you miss the
andy you've seen it right i've seen it
i've seen it
it's a good bit it's a good bit it's not
a bit
well it's getting hard now because my
son is like six two so i have to like
yeah he's right up here when i'm an old
man and they're like we love you daddy
you're leaving this earth oh my god
speaking of show business
first speaking of old man yeah
my children are deathly afraid of
becoming old men
like they start to cry and they'll ask
how old are they
they'll be five in two weeks and they
and they say
out of nowhere am i gonna be an old man
oh no and we say well you know what do
you think an old man
is and and they're like i don't know
just and then they imitate
an old man and it is their worst
nightmare they cry like tears in their
eyes and it comes up
i mean near daily am i gonna be an old
man
and what's crazy is stephanie's father
moved in with us and we ask
you know his po his name is papa grande
yeah it's his god-given name
and we say and his rapper name yeah
we say is papa grande an old man and
they say no
and we're like yeah yeah so where do
they get this
news flash oh yeah but i mean we don't
know what an
old man we don't know what happened
they're both terrified
that's so funny you've got to start
telling them from what i can tell being
an old man is fantastic
yeah because you get to say whatever you
want you get to be a complete pain in
the ass
and you can probably eat ice cream all
day i mean i even went to the point of
asking
am i an old man because we're trying to
understand and they're like
no right but we know they saw something
somewhere they saw an old man i saw an
old man definitely made a bad impression
on him yeah
but stephanie's father is not an old man
okay well
it may be that they just got out of the
phase of
pooping themselves and not being able to
walk very well and they don't want to go
back there any time soon
that's true you know how the end of life
and the beginning of life are very
similar yeah
diapers and all that yeah that could be
okay they're just
you know trying not to bend and butt
benjamin button it
they're always saying i just want to be
a kid forever
and they they love candy and toys
they're the most generic
children
[Laughter]
that's all your complaint is they're
generic
[Laughter]
they're so adorable but they are so
terrified to be old men
how much do you miss and i love talking
about your children but enough already
how much do you miss it's fair live
audiences
i mean you live for the laughter of a
crowd as do i
um we come alive yeah it's been um
it's been a little sad i told stephanie
um a couple of months into the pandemic
i said you do
know my career's over and she was like
ha
ha and i said why do you think i'm home
all the time my career is over right and
i mean i
acting is this side thing that i've done
or whatever i've done outside of stand
up is very much a
side gig right and it was
only about a month ago where she maybe
a couple of months ago where she said
gosh your career really
is over and that's nice you finally got
it took her a year and um but
i think that she and i
we really do make each other laugh so
much together and i think i've found
some sort of
fulfillment in that exchange and then
also
i started doing surprisingly a couple of
podcasts
and um and just exercising
the comedic muscle of uh
doing podcasts and hoping that um
people are laughing yeah that's i've
noticed
doing one that i i doing the one
that beat my podcast in the ambies
your podcast yes the much coveted ambi
award yes
hey that sounds like ambien i didn't
it's a it's a podcast award yes yeah um
your podcast
beat mine i was up against you okay well
i apologize
but i have two podcasts so i thought
maybe i had a better chance
at something no you cut your chances in
half by having two podcasts
that's what you did yeah damn it yeah
you have more
you could have twice as many fans as me
but half would vote for one podcast and
a half would vote for the other and you
it evened out and then i squeaked by
since you mocked the ambies can i have
your ambi award
i didn't mock the much coveted ambi
award it was an honor to get it
and i don't know where it's too late and
when i find out when i find out where it
is i'll cherish it
what were you going to say i interrupted
you i think i was saying something nice
about you and that's why you want
that's why you want to go back that's
why you want to pick up where we left
off
do you have cards no i don't i don't
have anything that would tell me what i
was talking about
damn it yeah but you feel like it was
nice it was i was going to say something
really complimentary that summed up
your genius it's gone
let's take time dead air is my favorite
no there's uh there's no way of
retrieving it
but i uh i'll be doing your podcast soon
yes you will it's called don't ask tig
yeah and i'm i'm coming on the podcast
and you'll treat me with great respect
won't you
i will i i will officially invite you at
some point but um
i know i'm just invited myself but i i
want to come on your podcast i think we
are magic together
i do too um i want to ask you about this
the
this it's incredible what's happened to
you
uh not that it's not deserved but your
career took this direction which
no one foresaw which is now you're a
a helicopter pilot in army of the dead
zack snyder's new offering yes and
it's this whole new you that none of us
saw coming i have here
this is i think the cover of metro
weekly
um i don't know if that's oh here it is
oh thank you very much a
burglar just handed me this this is you
on the cover
of metro weekly ticket tarot action
hero yeah that's incredible yeah it's
it's um didn't see that coming yeah and
then it says up here
scary good road head right we saw that
coming
um this is i mean you're an action star
now and you look the part you look cool
i know um well not i know i look cool
but i mean i do kind of know
you look cool yeah i mean i have to say
when they gave me that outfit
and i was doing my uh wardrobe changes
at home
yeah i walked out of and it was all in
my backyard i walked out into the
backyard kind of
like i think this is
how i'm supposed to be dressed like it
felt so right
i thought when they handed to me i was
like oh okay how funny
it's so crazy you were meant to be an
action star um
well i i i've done a little bit of
action on star trek
i mean i'm mainly just in sarcastic tig
in space
right um and then i mace mainly just
sarcastic
tig and helicopter running from from
zombies
uh it's a big deal working with uh with
zack snyder
yeah and i'm told you have a clip uh
this they're very secretive about the
project but this is a clip that you're
allowed to show is that right
yeah uh well there's been um
you know the movie it did really well i
think it's netflix's
biggest movie it's huge yeah that
they've ever put out
and um their sequels and prequels and
everything uh in the works and animated
series
and i've been asked if i'm a part of any
of that
and i have a very exciting
uh i have something very exciting to
share and it's that i am
in a um in a sequel you're in a sequel
yeah all right i understand this is
strategy a prequel or sequel i actually
don't know well it depends does it take
place afterwards or before
i know the difference between them but
nobody told me if this is a prequel or a
sequel
can't help you but this is i have
not only a clip from it but i have the
entire movie
you're going to show the entire movie
right now yeah let's take a look
wow i didn't see that ending coming
that's fantastic at the beginning
yeah but that middle part huh so that
cost
600 million dollars to make that's right
um
that's actually a digital did you know
that wasn't really me
could you tell i couldn't really tell
could you tell that wasn't
you play it again not a good job but
it's a digital
recreation of your creation of my whole
body
and zach made i think your ride's here
pig
this it's a ridiculous place to shoot a
show
it says there's a clown car out front
trying to get our attention
nice yeah that's one of my uh famous
that's one of your impressions
yeah there's a truck
there's a truck backing up in the alley
and there's a car out front
leaning on the horn a clown out back
i could just interrupt my own interview
and just while you're talking here let's
do it ask me a question
anyway
[Music]
we don't need this circuit i don't need
these idiots around this theater
[Music]
[Laughter]
army of the dead i'm gonna keep going
army of the dead is available now on
netflix
and uh tigg's podcast don't ask tig and
tegan
cheryl true story are both available
wherever you get your podcasts
and i'm going to be on don't ask tig yes
but tig and cheryl
is the podcast i do with cheryl hines
yeah curb your enthusiasm she's
hilarious
she is incredible we talk about we very
loosely talk about
a new documentary every week and i mean
very loosely
very loosely meaning you haven't
probably seen it uh
love talking to you and uh we our paths
will cross again
soon i do promise you okay well your
office is
down the street from my house yes it is
and i see you all the time take notaro
take a break we'll be right back